[Music]
the spider verse gets even bigger in
June 2023 with a sequel that goes all
out here's all you'll need to know
before you go across the spiderverse
with Miles Morales June 2023 is going to
be a huge month for movie fans Indiana
Jones is coming back for one last ride
in dial of Destiny the flash will bring
the Scarlet Speedster to the big screen
once again Optimus Prime and Optimus
primewar will join forces and
Transformers rise of the beasts whereas
Anderson will make his Grand pastel
colored return in Asteroid City and if
you'd rather just stay home Chris
Hemsworth will be beating up plenty of
bad guys and Netflix's extraction 2. to
kick off all that competition Spider-Man
across the spider-verse will be swinging
into theaters as the month begins on
June 2nd will the movie be able to hold
its ground against the competition we
have a hunch that miles on the other
spider people will do just fine still
it'll be interesting to see how the
critics reviews and box office numbers
of across the spider-verse they're
against those of The Flash 28 18s into
the spider-verse has hailed as an
all-time great superhero flick and many
hold our hope that the upcoming Flash
Film which comes out June 16th will
similarly be an instant classic the
first spider-verse also helped introduce
audiences to the concept of superhero
multiverses which The Flash is
capitalizing on what's going to happen
when these two Heroes compete on theater
screens we can't wait to find out one's
big Stakes how about multiversal Stakes
according to the official plot synopsis
for across the spider-verse the story
will kick off after Miles Morales
reunites with Gwen Stacy from there
Brooklyn's full-time friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man is catapulted
across the Multiverse where he
encounters a team of spider people
charged with protecting his very
existence but when the heroes Clash on
how to handle a new threat miles finds
himself pitted against the other spiders
and must redefine what it means to be a
hero so he can save the people he loves
most that new threat is most likely the
spot a lesser known Spidey villain whose
body is covered in interdimension
internal portals that enable him to jump
through space and across universes
don't don't do
don't do so it looks like miles will be
clashing with Miguel O'Hara also known
as Spider-Man 2099 the leader of an
interdimensional group of spider people
O'Hara has a very different philosophy
when it comes to protecting the
Multiverse as for all those multiversal
worlds we know the movie will visit five
different universes Spider-Man 2099's
Nueva York Gwen Stacy's Earth 65 the
India influenced mumbatin the punk
inspired New London and a fifth world
that hasn't been revealed yet each world
will have its own unique animation style
the movie will also focus on the
grubbing romance between miles and Gwen
with director Ken Powers telling Empire
that there will be something of a love
triangle between miles Gwen and the new
character spider Punk several of the
major players from into the spider-verse
are returning for the sequel Jamaica
Moore who voices Miles Morales is back
in the role and Haley Steinfeld is
returning to play Gwen Stacy Jake
Johnson is also coming back as Peter B
Parker he's a father now to daughter
Mayday Parker
[Music]
speaking of parents Brian Tyree Henry
and Luna Velez are returning to play
miles's dad and mom Oscar Isaac was also
reprise the role of Spider-Man 2099 this
futuristic hero showed up in an into the
spider-verse post-credits scene hoping
to explore other universes where you
want to go first let's start at the
beginning one last time
Earth 67. he looks a big antagonistic
force and across the spiderverse butting
heads with miles on how to save the
world and more importantly whom to save
Daniel kaluya joins a cast to play Hobie
Brown the spider Punk and Issa Ray will
voice the pregnant Jessica drew the
original Spider-Woman will also get to
hear Karen Sony as Spider-Man India as
for the universe hopping the spots Jason
swartzman will be hopping in to voice
the Buddy yellow moon to Coney of the
Lonely Island will voice a scary looking
version of the vulture and you can also
expect to hear the vocal stylings of
Rachel Dratch Jay Wiggum and Greta Lee
across the spider-verse boasts multiple
spider people and the film also boasts
multiple directors by Kim dos Santos
Kemp powers and Justin Kate Thompson are
all at the helm of this sequel the
Santos has a lot of Animation experience
was directing credits on a claimed
series such as avatar The Last Airbender
and Justice League Unlimited as for
Powers he earned an Oscar nomination for
adapting 2020s One Night in Miami he
also wrote and co-directed Pixar's Soul
as for Thompson he's been involved in
animation for quite some time serving as
a production designer on titles like
Cloudy with a Chance of Meatballs too
and the first spider-verse film this is
an incredibly talented lineup of
filmmakers and we can't wait to see how
their varying Styles blend together in
this exciting superhero story they seem
pretty psyched themselves in a joint
statement of variety the three directors
said the crew behind Spider-Man into the
spider-verse sets such a ridiculously
high bar and were humble to take on the
challenge of charting the next chapter
in the stories of Miles Morales we can't
wait to surprise fans of the wild new
adventure as sending miles on with his
friends both old and new
Phil Lord and Chris Miller have built up
quite a shared Hollywood resume they
cooked up Cloudy with a Chance of
Meatballs took us back to high school
with 21 Jump Street and created a whole
world out of plastic bricks with the
Lego Movie they've also produced a ton
of films from cocaine bear to the
Mitchells versus the machines these two
are also key to the success of into the
spider-verse serving as producers and
with Lord working on the story now
they're back for across the spite of us
and they're writing the screenplay with
Dave Callahan while you might not
recognize color Ham's name you've
definitely seen some of his movies his
credits include 2021's Mortal Kombat
Wonder Woman 1984 and Shang Chi and the
legend of the ten rings in addition to
co-writing the script Lord and Miller
are also producing the pick along with
some pretty key Hollywood players
there's longtime Marvel executive RV
Awad as well as Amy Pascal the former
head of Sony Pictures Entertainment
they'll be joined by Christina Steinberg
who produced into the spider-verse and
titles such as National Treasure and
Rise of the Guardians the two official
trailers for across the spider-verse
show off its huge cast of characters and
beautifully designed Worlds the first
trailer does a great job of setting the
tone for what we're about to witness
giving us glimpses of emotional moments
and action-packed brawls miles and Gwen
share a sweet rooftop moment Jessica
Drew battles a vulture while atop a
motorcycle our hero finds himself at us
with basically every spider person in
the Multiverse as the trailer plays out
miles's mom gives him words of
encouragement telling him to take care
of himself that little boy she's raised
and loved and makes sure he never
forgets where he came from wherever you
go from here you have to promise to take
care of that little boy for me
we have a feeling all that will play
pretty heavily into the events of the
film as Spider-Man 2099 seemingly
doesn't want miles involved at all in
his Society of Spider-Man a second
trailer delves more into the plots as it
confused miles encounters the spots
whose portals make him a particularly
tricky villain to deal with he also
reunites with Peter B Parker spider punk
rock sounds and Spider-Man India Souls
across the screen it also seems that
miles's secret superhero life might be
causing some Conflict at home and the
trailer hints that his family life might
play a huge part in the film at one
point we see miles has died in serious
Peril and that's when Spider-Man 2099
says that being Spider-Man is a
sacrifice adding you have a choice
between saving one person
and saved in every world
ever the true hero miles plans on saving
everyone and he refuses to let anyone
dictate how he lives his life saying
that he's going to do his own thing
multiverses are all the rage right now
especially in the world of Marvel
obviously across the spider verse will
deal with multiple dimensions and in the
MCU Heroes Have Been popping between
different timelines and universes in
series like Loki and movies like Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania of course one
of the most notable MCU projects to deal
with multiverses was Spider-Man no way
home which found Peter Parker and
Stephen Strange up against a sudden
influx of alternate reality bad guys and
different versions of Spider-Man that
event was so huge that it seems to have
caused Miguel O'Hara's attention in the
second official trailer for across the
spider-verse the arrays hero starts
ranting about the events of no way home
telling miles don't even get me started
on Doctor Strange and the Little Nerd
back on Earth 1999.99 so it seems like
Sony's animated world may be a part of
this larger fabric of spider universes
that includes Tom Holland Andrew
Garfield and Toby Maguire interestingly
this does call a few things into
question in Doctor Strange to the
Multiverse of Madness it's made clear
that strange lives on Earth 616 which is
the main Marvel Universe in the comics
however O'Hara says strange lives on
Earth
19999 which was the mcu's designation
dating back to a reference in 2008's
official Handbook of the Marvel Universe
A to Z volume 5. while Multiverse of
Madness seems to have changed things up
it looks like Spider-Man 2099 has a
different numbering system in mind some
mom will have to clear all this up there
is little denying that Spider-Man into
the spider-verse was a huge success for
Sony not only did it receive critical
and fun Acclaim and win a number of
high-profile Awards but the film was
also a commercial success grossing more
than 375 million dollars at the box
office so it shouldn't come as much of a
surprise that a sequel would be on the
way but it isn't just Spider-Man across
the spiderverse that's slated for
release Sony has also greenlit several
spin-offs as well according to an
exclusive report from deadline Meg Smith
is writing a Spider Woman film that will
feature three different generations of
superheroes who all have powers similar
to Spider-Man several producers and
writers from Spider-Man into the
spider-verse are also said to be
involved including Amy Pascal and RV
Awad meanwhile Chris Miller has also
revealed that he and Phil Lord are also
developing a number of television series
based on Marvel characters some of which
are connected to the spider-verse
franchise although he would not give out
any concrete details along with the
upcoming sequel fans of the spider-verse
will get another dose of the web
slinging hero in 2023 with the release
of a short called the spider within
variety reports such a short film will
chart the anxiety that Miles Morales
suffers from as he tries to be a
superhero while also trying to live the
typical life of a teenager it will also
look at how important it is to seek help
when things get tough a spider within is
being developed as parts of Sony's
leading and empowering new storytellers
program which is meant to give talented
creatives from backgrounds that are
underrepresented in the movie and
television Industries a platform to show
their talent they're sure to set to
arrive in June around the same time that
across the spiderverse will hit Cinema
screens it will first be shown at the
anisee international animation Film
Festival before being released to The
Wider public
when Sony first revealed the title for
the into the spider-verse sequel it also
confirmed that it wouldn't be the only
sequel in fact the second movie was
initially unveiled under the title
Spider-Man across the spider-verse part
1 suggesting that the second and third
films are strongly connected and would
effectively tell one continuous story
Phil Lord and Chris Miller later
explained that when they started to
write the film they had too many ideas
to fit into a single release so they
began working on two movies at the same
time at Cinema con 2022 the filmmakers
revealed the new title for the third
movie Spider-man beyond the spiderverse
all indications are it will continue the
story from Spider-Man across the
spider-verse and follow Miles Morales
and the other spotted people who make up
its cast we're wondering if across the
spider verse will have some sort of
cliffhanger ending Mentor sets up beyond
the spiderverse which will be released
on March 29 2024 speaking with Empire
producer Miller compared across the
spider verse to The Empire Strikes Back
saying it shows you worlds you haven't
seen and as an emotional story that ends
at a place where you need to see the
third one it is not unusual for animated
films to take a lot longer to produce
some typical live-action releases
animation can be a very labor intensive
process and 3D computer animation can
take huge amounts of time to render this
means that animated movies can have
hundreds of people as part of the
production crew or working on different
aspects of the project to get it out in
a reasonable time frame a good example
is The Lion King the 1994 movie that was
a part of the Disney Renaissance and was
one of the last traditionally animated
releases from the company around 600
animators artists and technicians were
involved in their production from
misconception until they hit Cinema
screens meanwhile the CGI Frozen 2 from
2019 had a team that was 800 people
strong working on the project Spider-Man
across the spiderverse puts all of these
numbers to shame the new film had more
than 1 000 people as part of the crew
with Phil Lord and Chris Miller telling
deadline that it has the largest crew of
any animated movie ever ever made
significantly more than worked on the
first film when discussing the sheer
size of Spider-Man across the
spiderverse for deadline Phil Lord and
Chris Miller spoke about the vast number
of characters that would be in the movie
they also joked that CEO of Sony
Pictures Motion Picture group Tom
Rothman wasn't aware of the scale of
their project saying don't tell Tom the
number of characters this movie has 240
characters considering that the film
will feature five different dimensions
including a secret one that has yet to
be revealed there are a lot of places
for various Heroes villains and other
variants to appear some of the more
obscure versions of Spidey who have been
confirmed for Spider-Man across the
spider-verse include the bombastic Bug
Man and the amazing spider monkey but
some fans haven't seen yet that could
show up in the series include the
cowboy-like web Slinger and Mexican hero
arachnido Jr an Otto Octavius Fusion
known as The Superior Spider-Man and the
infamous Venom it's likely though that
fans won't get a full picture of exactly
who is included in the film until they
hit see it says in June maybe I should
go to New York and speak to the South
Spider-Man every major movie comes with
marketing deals that help spread the
word about the film and bring in some
extra Revenue but just two examples
Spider-Man into the spider-verse are
promotional Partnerships with Super
League Gaming and General Mills offering
people the chance to experience video
game challenges based on the movie as
well as buy boxes of cereal with free
spider-verse stickers inside so it
shouldn't be a huge shock to learn that
Sony already has a few marketing deals
in place ahead of the release of
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
deadline reported in 2020 that Sony had
teamed up with Hyundai to include
vehicles and Technology from the
automaker in the movie as well as
several other releases from the film
studio there will also be a series of 15
Funko Pop figures based on characters
and events from the 2023 movie including
Spider-Man India spider Gwen and Miles
Morales Spider-Man into the spider-verse
had a soundtrack that included a
traditional film score and a mixture of
previously released music from pop music
artists including DJ Khalil post Malone
and Nicki Minaj the score was composed
by Daniel Pemberton an award-winning
musician who also worked on DC's Birds
of Prey and Netflix's Black Mirror the
good news for fans of the first film is
that Pemberton is returning for the
sequel he told polygon of the new film
score it's the most complicated out
there crazy score I've probably ever
written Pemberton went on to give an
idea of what viewers can expect to hear
when they see the film saying it will
include drum solos Opera vocals punk
rock Indian percussion techno drums
extreme time stretching emotional
orchestration upper jarot hard sense and
crazy sound design Phil Lord and Chris
Miller have also revealed that
Spider-Man across the spider-verse will
have music from record producer and DJ
Metro Boomin the musician has released
two albums of superhero themed music and
according to hyper Beast he will create
music for the film that the writers
believe Miles Morales would listen to
Chris Anker is probably best known for
his work in a variety of Marvel Comics
he has previously provided artwork for a
number of high-profile series including
X-Men Captain Marvel runaways and
Star-Lord it contributes here to 2015
spider-verse number two and has drawn
variant covers for the Miles Morales
Spider-Man series and Edge of
spider-verse in 2020 CBR reported that
Anker was involved in Spider-Man across
the spider verse although it didn't
detail exactly what his role in the
production was things changed a few
months later when the artist replied to
her question on Twitter to confirm that
he was working on the movie full-time as
a character designer anchor certainly
has plenty of experience in character
design he modernized the look of the
Jessica Drew version of Spider-Woman in
2015.
[Music]